der Haussegen in den Krankenhäusern
hängt schief genervtes überarbeitetes
Personal verunsicherte Patienten
gleichzeitig laufen sie kosten davon die
Panikattacken hat inzwischen die Politik
erreicht denn spätestens bei der
Gesundheit wird der Spaß auf
fliegenotstand Personalmangel
Pleitewelle Krankenhäuser am Limit jetzt
in der phönix-runde
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
Tina Rudolf ist bei uns Ärztin
medizinetikerin und
Gesundheitspolitikerin und sie sitzen
für die SPD im Bundestag und sind dort
Mitglied im Gesundheitsausschuss
Erwin rüttel ist ebenfalls
Gesundheitspolitiker ebenfalls Mitglied
des Bundestages sie sind in der
Unionsfraktion aber auch Mitglied im
Gesundheitsausschuss des Bundestages
Reinhard Busse ist Professor für
Management im Gesundheitswesen an der
Technischen Universität Berlin und
Mitglied der Regierungskommission von
Karl Lauterbach für die
krankenhausreform schließlich Tim Arnold
sie sind
Intensivmediziner hier an der Charité in
Berlin dort haben sie ja mit ihren
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Anfang des
Monats gestreikt und für bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen demonstrieren aus
dieser Kundgebung herr Arnold haben sie
ein Satz gesagt der es in die
Hauptnachrichtensendungen des Fernsehens
am geschafft hat sie nämlich gesagt
die Liebe zu ihrem Beruf als Arzt sei
verstorben
Arzt oder Ärztin wird man ja wohl aus
Leidenschaft wie konnte es soweit kommen
ja die kondensationsmechanismen haben
sich im Laufe der Zeit erschöpft die
Selbstaufgabe ist doch immer mehr in den
Vordergrund getreten die Belastungen
sind immer mehr geworden und ja
irgendwann ist die Liebe zum Beruf dann
erloschen tatsächlich Busse was hat zu
diesen Arbeitsbedingungen in den
Kliniken geführt naja erstaunlicherweise
vielleicht vor paradoxes ist wir haben
zu viele Kliniken die zu wenig
spezialisiert sind und wir tun ganz
wichtig zu viele Patienten werden in
Deutschland stationär behandelt so dass
die Ressource Personal nicht nicht nur
Ärzte auf Pflegepersonal verschwendet
wird und wir da dringend dringend ran
müssen also weniger ist gleichzeitig
mehr für die für die für das Personal
aber auch für die Patienten und das ist
glaube ich das große um irgendwas vor
uns liegt
Rudolf es geht ja um Personalmangel in
dieser Sendung vor allen Dingen ihr
Parteifreund und
Bundesgesundheitsminister plant ja jetzt
die größte krankenhausreform seit 20
Jahren ist das Problem Personalmangel in
Kliniken also sowohl für die Ärzteschaft
wie auch für das Pflegepersonal dann
beseitigt
ich die Zahlen anguckt dann haben wir
gerade zu einigen anderen europäischen
Ländern eher einen relativen
Personalmangel also wir haben eigentlich
relativ viel Personal und ich glaube
aber dass alle die die in der Praxis
arbeiten schon sagen würden dass die
Arbeitsbedingungen das nicht immer
widerspiegeln und dass wir einfach
deswegen zu diesen strukturellen
Verbesserungen kommen müssen die auch
gerade angesprochen worden sind dass wir
damit alle Probleme lösen das darf man
im Gesundheitssystem so nie behaupten
aber das ist auf jeden Fall der Start
den wir jetzt sagen müssen und das sind
längst überfälligere Formen und deswegen
bin ich sehr froh dass wir in dieser
Legislaturperiode da wirklich ein
Schritt weiterkommen werden
Krankenhäusern heißt also das
unterentable Kliniken zum Beispiel
geschlossen werden dass das hat Busse
damit ja auch gemeint mit seiner
Äußerung eben verstärkt auf ambulante
Versorgung wo es möglich ist gesetzt
wird und die stationäre zurückgefahren
wird aber wie gesagt das bedeutet das
unrentable Kliniken geschlossen werden
müssen wahrscheinlich das hört man im
ländlichen Raum nicht so gern ist das
trotzdem unausweichlich also nach meiner
Meinung brauchen wir mehr
Spezialisierung
Spezialisierung wird dazu führen dass
gerade im ländlichen Bereich nicht jedes
Krankenhaus sich spezialisieren kann und
deshalb müssen wir die Krankenhäuser im
ländlichen Bereich weiterentwickeln zu
multifunktionalen Versorgungszentren wo
also
stationäre Versorgung Tagesklinik und
ambulante Versorgung umgesetzt wird und
wir müssen uns dann auch für den
ländlichen Raum die Frage stellen ob
also eine doppelte fahrradschiene
überall umsetzbar ist also wir müssen
das heißt also das ist Fachärzte
sozusagen
niedergelassen ambulant gibt und im
Grunde die Parallelstruktur noch mal im
Krankenhaus da das ist sind sicherlich
dicke Bretter die gebohrt werden müssen
und nach meiner Meinung muss der Bund
einsteigen über Qualität in die
Krankenhausplanung und die Länder haben
hätten dann die Aufgabe in den Regionen
Planungen zu machen damit die Menschen
sicher sein können dass in ihrem Umfeld
Gesundheitsversorgung sichergestellt ist
und ich glaube es fragt kein Patient
danach wenn die Versorgung gut ist ob
die Versorgung stationär oder ambulant
umgesetzt wird sondern hauptsache sie
wird auch ortsnah und zeitnah erleben
wobei wahrscheinlich die Krankenkassen
dann danach fragen
das klang bei Ihnen wieder so unrentabel
als ob es immer nur ums Geld geht bei
der Krankenhaus sofort es geht eben
nicht nur nicht nur ums Geld
unrentabel klingt gleich so die machen
Verlust wir müssen wissen wir haben am
Tag 500 Bürger erleiden Herzinfarkt die
werden bei uns in 1000 Krankenhäusern
behandelt von denen aber nur 500 ein
Herzkatheterlabor haben und es geht
jetzt darum die Bürger wegen der
Qualität nicht weil wir nicht weil die
Häuser finanziell schlecht sind dass wir
sagen wir verteilen die die 500
Patienten mit Herzinfarkt genau auf die
500 Häuser die linksherzkatheter haben
und natürlich geht es den Häusern die
keinen haben geht es nicht nur mit dem
Herzkatheter so geht's die haben keine
Schlaganfall Einheit sich dies nicht das
es geht nicht darum ob dieses schwarze
oder rote Zahlen schreiben es geht darum
dass es gar nicht genug Patienten gibt
die tatsächlich dort adäquat versorgt
werden können es ist ja immer wieder
gesagt worden es würde würden viele
stationär behandelt werden die man auch
ambulante behandeln kann die man am
Abend nach Hause schicken kann auf gut
deutsch wie ist das ihrer Sicht ist
lässt sich da tatsächlich aus diesem
Gebiet zwischen ambulanter und
stationärer Behandlung etwas tun eben
auch um Kosten einzusparen sicherlich
kann man da was machen ich glaube wir
dürfen nur nicht vergessen dass wir
natürlich auch vor einer zunehmenden
Alterung der Gesellschaft irgendwo
konfrontiert sind und von den gerade die
älteren Patienten häufiger stationäre
Aufenthalte brauchen weil die Versorgung
anders gar nicht sinnvoll möglich ist
tatsächlich und da sehe ich vor allen
Dingen auch ein Problem in der
Spezialisierung der Kliniken sind gerade
ältere geriatrische Patienten wie wir
sie nennen haben häufig nicht nur ein
Problem sondern haben eben viele
verschiedene Probleme wo man jemanden
braucht der einen guten allgemeinen
Blick hat und eben nicht den
Spezialisten der sich nur mit der linken
Herzkammer beschäftigt und schon nicht
mehr weiß was die rechte Herzkammer tut
das ist eine Gefahr die ich sehe im
Rahmen dieser
spezialisierungsforderung tatsächlich
auf der anderen Seite ist es ja
strukturell so dass die Spezialisierung
besser bezahlt wird und deswegen auch
gerade kleine Kliniken die Anreize haben
unbedingt Fachabteilung vorhalten zu
müssen und wenn wir das schaffen dieser
Anreize auszuweiten und besser zu
gestalten dass eben vor allem diese
Vorhaltekosten besser finanziert werden
und deswegen die strukturerhaltung auch
in der Fläche sich lohnt eben über
andere Mechanismen ich glaube dann haben
wir einiges gewonnen sie kommt auf die
Finanzierung doch zu sprechen es geht ja
um die bisherige gültigen Fallpauschalen
jetzt soll das ersetzt werden durch
Vorhaltekosten das eben tatsächlich
Gelder
patientengelder nicht quasi durch
wirtschaftliche Anreize zweckentfremdet
werden bei dieser
krankenhausreform die jetzt geplant ist
sie sind ja da zum Teil hier auch
involviert ist ja auch die Frage lässt
sich das so leicht umsetzen weil da
mischen ja unglaublich viele Leute mit
es gibt kaum eine stärkere an stärkeren
Lobbyismus als im Gesundheitswesen wenn
man frech ist oder man sagen viele Köche
verderben den Brei da ist er schon viel
versucht worden und vieles wurde auch
verschlimmbessert bei Reformen was macht
Sie sicher das ist diesmal besser wird
also was man jetzt tatsächlich
beobachten kann und das stimmt mich sehr
optimistisch dass alle den
Handlungsdruck erkannt haben und dass
wir teilweise gerade beobachten können
dass Stakeholder sich an einen Tisch
setzen miteinander reden und auch zu zu
guten Ergebnissen kommen bei dem man das
vorher vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt
erwartet hätte wenn wir als Beispiel zum
Beispiel die neue pflegepersonalregelung
nehmen die wir jetzt gerade in den
Gesetzgebungsprozess bekommen haben da
haben sich Verdi die Deutsche
Krankenhausgesellschaft und der
Pflegegrad hingesetzt und haben
gemeinsames gutes Papier vor zwei drei
Jahren auf dem Weg gebracht und das
zeigt genauso wie das auf Landesebene
jetzt auf der Falle ist wenn es um die
krankenhauspläne geht dass sich der
Akteure an einen Tisch setzen und
wirklich wissen wie groß der
Handlungsdruck ist und dass man zur
gemeinsamen Lösungen kommen muss da
glaube ich da haben wir auch Potenzial
also ich würde es nicht gleich schon mal
nicht reden dass natürlich aus vielen
Richtungen auch Verbesserungsvorschläge
kommen sobald es im
gesetzgebungsprozesse geht aber das
insgesamt wirklich von vielen Seiten
hier der gute Wille besteht dass wir da
was hinbekommen
habe also es geht nicht darum jetzt
Krankenhäuser reinweise zu schließen
sondern ihre Stärken auszubauen
Spezialisierungen heißt das dass man
also das Schließen von Krankenhäusern
weitgehend ausschließen kann nein weil
wir haben so viele also wir haben ja
deutlich mehr ist ich würde weniger die
Krankenhäuser erzählen als die Betten da
muss man sehen wenn wir uns so mit dem
Schnitt der Nachbarländer vergleichen
wir haben 50 Prozent also die Hälfte
mehr Betten und wir haben auch die
Hälfte mehr Patienten und das ist ganz
klar wenn wir eine sinnvolle neue
Versorgung machen ich nenne mir ein
Beispiel
was da ambulant machen können
Krebspatienten das ist nur ein ein
Beispiel wo wir wissen wie viele
Krebspatienten es gibt aber
Krebsregister haben wir behandeln jeden
Krebspatienten viermal stationär im
Schnitt unser Nachbarländern nur zweimal
weil die mehr ambulante Chemotherapie
machen wenn wir das jetzt rausziehen aus
dem Krankenhäusern dann bleiben
natürlich noch mehr leere Betten übrig
und es geht jetzt also aber andererseits
sind ja in vielen Gegenden auch die
krankenhausdichte ist so dicht dass wir
das Verdünnen können und dem Bürger
klarer machen wenn da jetzt Krankenhaus
draufsteht auf dem Gebäude was dann
übrig bleibt da steht Krankenhaus drauf
du wirst da aber auch gut versorgt heute
hat er die Wahl zwischen 10
Krankenhäuser und weiß gar nicht haben
die eigentlichen links Herzkatheter
machen die Krebs und darum ist sozusagen
weniger ist wirklich mehr das wird auch
für alle übersichtlicher und und und und
besser das heißt das würde ich trotzdem
mit Blick auf das föderale System machen
also ich glaube wir müssen trotzdem noch
mal die Unterscheidung ziehen und über
welche Bundesländer wir reden weil wir
doch auch sehen dass es einige
Bundesländer gibt bei denen diese
Strukturreformen also im Sinne von sind
viele Krankenhäuser umgewandelt worden
oder eben auch ausgedünnt schon in den
90ern passiert sind also ich glaube ob
man sich jetzt NRW oder Thüringen
anguckt das ist durchaus ein kleiner
Unterschied diese diese Krankenhäuser
die da möglicherweise jetzt umformiert
werden soll ist das was in vielen
Bereichen dann bei der ambulanten
Versorgung dass das die Menschen dann
antreffen werden diese so regionale
Versorgungszentren wo man auch gut
behandelt wird aber die keine
krankenhausstrukturen hat weil man sie
gar nicht mehr braucht an dieser Stelle
denkt die Entwicklung geht eindeutig in
Richtung ambulantisierung und ich habe
bei einem Parlamentarischen Abend gehört
dass der
dkg-vorsitzende DR Gass gesagt hat wir
haben zu viele Deutschen
Krankenhausgesellschaft selbst sagt wir
haben zu viele Betten und weil die
Menschen das ist meine Interpretation
gerade auch durch Corona Wege gesucht
haben sich nicht stationär behandeln zu
lassen wenn das eben möglich ist
zudem haben wir die Situation dass zu
viele zu viel machen ohne dass sie
perfekt diese Dinge oder Aufgaben
erledigen können weil sie einfach das
Geld brauchen also deshalb brauchen wir
diese Spezialisierung auch als
Patientenschutz aber auch zum Bündeln
von Kräften die wir dann einsetzen
können da wo also Ärzte und Pflegekräfte
fehlen für mich noch eine Bemerkung
machen darf sie haben gesagt die große
krankenhausreform also dann liegt ihnen
was vor was mir noch nicht vorliegt bis
jetzt ist das alles ich sage jetzt mal
Planung des Ministers und der Minister
hat in den letzten Monaten auch dieser
hat in den letzten Monaten sehr viele
Dinge angekündigt die ja bis jetzt nicht
umgesetzt hat was ich im Moment sehe ist
dass er Pflege dass er dass er eine
pflegere Form macht und da wird
festgeschrieben wie viel Pflege ideal
wäre aber ohne die Perspektiven zu
eröffnen wie viel wo ich die
Pflegekräfte her nehme und das was ich
höre in Sachen Kommissionen das also
mehr Geld für
Kinderkliniken Gynäkologie Pädiatrie das
ist sicherlich richtig aber das ist
keine Reform sondern das ist einfach
mehr Geld ins System und wir brauchen
jetzt eine Reform die eigentlich schon
vor der Pandemie in Angriff genommen
worden wäre wenn die pandem ja
Parteifreund Jens Spahn
Gesundheitsminister
das wollten wir machen in Verbindung mit
der Notfallversorgung also das ist ja
gut im Grunde genommen
höchste Zeit dass wir das jetzt in den
Griff kriegen und einen größere Form
machen mit so interessant die Diskussion
und der Mitglieder des
Gesundheitsausschusses des Bundestages
ist wir wollen aber natürlich auch uns
die Praxis ansehen also die politische
Ebene auch wieder verlassen Arnold es
war heißt jetzt
im Vorfeld einer zu erwartenden
corona-welle es gäbe wieder ein ein
geschenkten Betrieb auf den
Intensivstationen in vielen
Krankenhäusern ist die Notfallversorgung
bei uns akut gefährdet im Moment
die Notfallversorgung ist sichergestellt
das glaube ich kann man schon ganz klar
sagen aber wir sind in der Situation wo
wir uns große Sorgen machen müssen und
ich glaube man kann auch einen Fakt ganz
ehrlich sagen wir machen uns ja nicht
erst sorgen oder wir müssen uns erst
nicht Sorgen machen seit Corona Corona
ist ja nur der Gipfel gewesen eigentlich
ja das fast zum Überlaufen gebracht hat
sondern wir beklagen diese Probleme ja
seit vielen vielen Jahren und letztlich
glaube ich muss man ganz klar sagen wir
sind nicht gehört worden wir haben als
Ärzte sagen wir lange wir haben große
Herausforderungen wir haben große
Probleme und
als Beispiel kann ich nennen dass wir
eben eine ein Aktionsbündnis gestartet
haben Ende letzten Jahres intensiv am
Limit wir hatten Unterstützung von knapp
3000 vorwiegend Ärzten und Ärzten in
Ostdeutschland wo wir in Brandbrief
geschrieben haben und schon Ende letzten
Jahres auf diese Verschärfung der
Situation auf den Intensivstationen
hingewiesen haben dieser Brandbrief ist
dann adressiert worden an Herrn
Lauterbach und die Berliner Senatorin
für Gesundheit und Pflege wir haben bis
heute keine Antwort bekommen was finde
ich schon sehr gut zeigt dass wir als
Ärzte bislang nicht gehört wurden mit
unseren sorgen sie arbeiten ja an einer
der größten und renommiertesten Kliniken
in Deutschland der Charité jetzt ohne
Betriebsgeheimnisse zu verraten was
bedeutet denn das diese Situation ist
jetzt gerade skizziert haben zum
Beispiel für die Patientinnen und
Patienten die spüren das was ist wie
sieht ihr Arbeitsausfall Arbeitsalltag
aus
vielleicht eine skizzenhaft aber damit
wir uns mal eine Vorstellung machen
können
unterm Strich leiden wir unter
erheblichen Personalnot und zwar über
alle Fachbereiche hinaus wir wissen es
weil es viel in den Medien war von der
von dem Pflegepersonal her das ganze
gilt aber auch für den ärztlichen
Bereich es ist alles sehr auf Kante
genäht das wiederum bedeutet dass
natürlich wenn zu wenig Pflegepersonal
da ist die Arbeit auch von den Ärzten
mit übernommen werden muss das wiederum
führt zu einem personaldefizit in der
ärztlichen Versorgung wenn wir wiederum
ein personaldefizit sind heißt das dass
wir unsere Entscheidungen deutlich
zügiger treffen müssen dass wir
vielleicht deutlich weniger Zeit haben
das ganze zu reflektieren dass wir keine
Pausen finden aber auch das Angehörigen
und patientengespräche deutlich kürzer
treten müssen weil uns einfach
schlichtweg durch diese
arbeitsübernahmen die Zeit fehlt sie
haben lange Bereitschaftsdienste lange
aktive Dienste sie haben auch darauf
hingewiesen dass es hier für andere
Berufsgruppen wie Piloten oder
Kraftfahrer
arbeitszeitbeschränkungen gibt für Ärzte
gibt es das nicht jetzt die sagen
dass ein übermüdeter Pilot kein
Sicherheit vermitteln kann ist klar aber
ein übermittelter Arzt genauso wenig
also das heißt gefährdet ja
möglicherweise auch Menschenleben
für die Pflege auch
wie muss man sich das vorstellen ich
meine sie haben ja auch eine enorme
Verantwortung und sind möglicherweise am
Ende ihrer Kräfte ja also das kann man
definitiv so sagen wir leisten
Bereitschaftsdienste von bis zu 16
Stunden und normalerweise ist es ja so
dass die Bereitschaftszeit dann eben
maximal 50 Prozent sein sollte häufig
ist es so dass wir 80 Prozent aktive
Arbeit leisten kann man sich selber sehr
schnell ausrechnen wie viel aktiv Zeit
das dann ist
dass das nicht gut ist glaube ich ist
kein Geheimnis und man muss sich eben
vorstellen der Stresslevel ist enorm es
klingelt dauerhaft das Telefon wir sind
zuständig für extremst kranke Patienten
und dass man an seine Grenzen gelangt
glaube ich leuchtet jedem ein
wenn Sie das jetzt hören der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat ja auch
ein Krankenhaus
pflegeentlastungsgesetz wie das glaube
ich heißt auf den Weg gebracht oder will
das auf den Weg bringen einer der
üblichen Band wurden Begriffe aber was
lässt sich damit Regeln und verbessern
wenn Sie jetzt das ist ja sicherlich
nicht dem anderen nicht der einzige der
solche Erfahrungen macht
am tirol hat er auch schon einen
wichtigen Punkt angesprochen also
erstmal eine valide bedarfsvermessung zu
haben das muss natürlich der erste
Schritt sein deswegen ist dieses Gesetz
auch gut
und trotzdem haben sie insofern Recht
einen Bedarf zu konstatieren heißt noch
nicht dass man den sofort decken kann da
würde ich jetzt auch gar nicht so weit
gehen dass das nicht die Vorgänge
Regierungen also auch in der
spd-beteiligung nicht schon versucht
hätte wir hatten das Pflegestellen
Sofortprogramm 13.000 stellen es hat
dann nicht am Geld gemacht die letzten
Endes sondern wir konnten diese ständig
besetzen und das ist eine Personalmangel
mit dem wir uns im Gesundheitswesen
konfrontiert sind bei dem ich jetzt auch
der Politik nicht unterstellen möchte
dass sie das wirklich erst seit gestern
weiß aber wir brauchen einfach noch
besser Lösungsansätze dafür und zwar
über mehrere Ebenen da gibt es keine
einweglösung für dieses Problem und das
sind einerseits strukturelle Dinge also
zu sagen wie schaffen wir es mit etwas
weniger Personalbedarf bei
gleichzeitiger Versorgungsqualität für
die Patientinnen und Patienten was Gutes
hinzubekommen wie schaffen wir es
gleichzeitig Ausbildung auf dem hohen
Niveau zu halten also auch für Nachwuchs
zu sorgen die Berufe attraktiv zu halten
dass eben auch Menschen in die Pflege
und bei medizinstühlen muss man sich die
sorgen jetzt nicht machen also ist ja
immer noch so dass viele Menschen gerne
studieren möchten und es eben zu wenig
Studien gibt und gleichzeitig sind
gerade medizinsturmplätze auch natürlich
immer sehr teuer für die Länder aber da
einerseits für einen guten Nachwuchs zu
sorgen Arbeitsbedingungen so attraktiv
zu halten dass Menschen nicht aus dem
finanzielle Gründe das ist so wenig
Medizinstudienplätze gibt weil das wird
ja immer wieder immer wieder gefordert
also kann ich auch aus Thüringer als
Beispiel mit mit berichten dass wir da
schon die Anzahl der Studienplätze
erhöht haben ist auch vom Landtag
natürlich gerne so entschieden worden
und trotzdem irgendwann haben sie auch
eine Kapazität eine Problem das andere
ist glaube ich
dass wir das ja viele Ärzte Ärztinnen
und Ärzte Babyboomer sind die nächsten
fünf bis sieben Jahren in Ruhestand
gehen ich glaube das ist fast die Hälfte
aller Ärzte
da ist er irgendwie schon Feuer unterm
Dach das ungefähr eine genauso lang wie
eine Medizinstudium dauert und die die
nachkommen wollen in der Regel nicht so
viele Stunden im System arbeiten
live-balance wie das die
Vorgängergeneration gemacht hat
sage nur was sozusagen fakt ist dass das
was also Statistik belegt und das weiß
man in den Ländern schon seit ich hätte
fast gesagt seit Jahrzehnten wir
brauchen mehr Ärztinnen und Ärzte und
dafür braucht man mehr Studienplätze und
wenn man die Studienplätze letztendlich
deckelt oder jetzt vor ein zwei Jahren
auf die Idee kommen wir erhöhen das
leicht dann dauert das aber auch 15
Jahre bis dann diese jungen Menschen im
Beruf sind das heißt der Fehler ist
gemacht worden in den Ländern
wird keine Krankenhausplanung gemacht
und das werden zu wenig Ärzte
ausgebildet und wir müssen jetzt
versuchen über Strukturreformen diese
Probleme zu lösen und da haben wir nicht
allzu viel Zeit und der Minister hat
nach meiner Meinung schon ein Jahr
verblempert mit Corona österien statt
sich um die wahren Probleme zu kümmern
wieso ist das so schwer zu planen als
ich kann mich erinnern als ich Abitur
gemacht habe hier es gab viel zu viele
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer Ergebnis war 20
Jahre später gab es ein riesen
Lehrermangel in den meisten
Bundesländern
was ist daran so schwer das zu erkennen
dass man entsprechend da braucht man
auch eine lange Vorlaufzeit das
entsprechend zu planen naja weil muss
man sagen das hängt natürlich auch davon
ab wie das Tätigkeitsprofil der
verschiedenen Berufe ist also wir haben
zum einen die der das
erkrankungsspektrum der Bevölkerung wie
viele Kranke wie viel gesunde gibt es
was für was für Krankheiten haben die
tauchen krank werden Krankheiten
Behandlungs behandelbar Krebs zum
Beispiel war vor vor Jahrzehnten konnte
man da nicht viel machen jetzt kann man
was machen braucht man natürlich auch
entsprechend auch Ärzte wenn Ärzte aber
was in Deutschland leider der Fall ist
abgesehen davon wieder zu davon akuten
Verschiebung machen ärz in Deutschland
Tätigkeiten die in anderen Ländern das
Pflegepersonal macht also insofern ist
auch das wären wesentlicher Faktor wenn
wir sagen Ärzte sind sind knapp
überlegen wir doch mal ob deren
Tätigkeit wirklich immer von Ärzten
gemacht werden muss dann würde man Teil
könnte durch durch weiter qualifizierte
Pflegekräfte übernommen werden natürlich
die sind auch knapp aber dann gibt es
wiederum Dinge die die von anderen
übernommen werden müssen also das ganze
Tätigkeitsprofil muss man natürlich
überprüfen man würde gleichzeitig die
Berufe attraktiver machen weil die bei
die Ärzte wollen eigentlich die
pflegerischen Tätigkeiten gar nicht
unbedingt mit man die Pfleger die
Pfleger würden gerne von Welt von denen
welche übernehmen und gleichzeitig sagen
wir mal dass das Essen austeilen an die
Patienten natürlich nicht machen das
könnten im Extremfall auch Roboter
machen wenn man er hat nach Japan gucken
fahren da Roboter und fahren das Essen
aus weil das Personal ist natürlich
überall knapp wir dürfen jetzt ja nicht
denken im Gesundheitswesen ist es super
knapp also soll jetzt jeder dritte jeder
dritte Pfleger oder Arzt werden in
anderen Branchen ist es ganz genauso und
das hat ich meine wir lange von der
demografischen Tradition gesprochen und
uns war eigentlich immer klar die würde
ab 2020 kommen dann dachten alle es ist
Corona nee war gar nicht war gar nicht
Corona weil jeder dachte oh mein
Personal ist in anderen Sektor
abgewandert aber aber es ist in jedem
Sektor so und das ist jetzt sie haben es
schon gesagt mit den babybooman daran
müssen wir uns jetzt jetzt jetzt
gewöhnen und müssen wirklich grundlegend
diskutieren die Reform im
Gesundheitswesen wird nicht darauf
setzen können dass es deutlich mehr
Personal gibt darf es einmal doch ein
bisschen differenzierter fassen also in
der Pflege zum Beispiel kann man ja
schon beobachten dass die mittlere
Verweildauer im Beruf einfach kürzer ist
als im anderen Berufen also wenn jemand
im Schnitt nicht mal zehn Jahre in der
Pflege bleibt dann geht uns da ein
Potenzial verloren die Menschen haben
die Ausbildung gemacht die haben sich
für diesen Beruf entschieden die wollten
in dem Beruf arbeiten die meisten machen
das auch gerne mit Herzblut und dann
trotzdem früher auszusteigen das ist
schon auch ein Hinweis genau
Arbeitsbedingungen und nur auf den
allgemeinen Fachkräftemangel aber wir
brauchen viel mehr zusätzlich noch und
deshalb also wenn man so weiter und
deshalb brauchen wir diese
Strukturreformen und müssen also die
Kräfte bündeln vielleicht darf ich noch
einen einen Satz dazu sagen ich glaube
das ist ein Kernpunkt den sie gerade
getroffen haben dass wir Aufgaben aus
dem ärztlichen Bereich die diese
Expertise nicht benötigen unbedingt
herausnehmen müssen ich habe mich mit
vielen Kollegen nochmal unterhalten vor
der Sendung das war der Haupttenor der
eigentlich ein Riesenproblem ist
tatsächlich und wenn man sich überlegt
als Facharzt mit vielen Jahren
Berufserfahrung mit was für Dingen ich
mich jeden Dienst rumschlagen muss
Dokumentationspflichten Scores die
abrechnungsrelevant sind wo man einfach
Tabellen auswertet das kann jeder ohne
jeden medizinischen Sachverstand das
traurige daran ist es hat in den letzten
zehn Jahren erheblich zugenommen und
nicht abgenommen insofern ist es schon
interessant dass man jetzt plötzlich auf
die Idee kommt und sagt Mensch das
müssen wir jetzt ändern im ambulanten
Bereich hat sind aber auch viele unserer
ärztlichen Kollegen gerade die Vertreter
der Kassenärztlichen Vereinigung sind
dagegen das ärztliche Tätigkeit durch
Pflegekräfte
die werden dir übers Land fahren ersetzt
werden das natürlich pervers das
sozusagen wir ein einerseits sagen
ärztliche Tätigkeit ist knapp aber wir
geben wir geben keine Tätigkeiten ab da
müssen wir wirklich ran und die Reform
sieht man schon an vielen Punkten die
darf sich auch nicht nur auf dem
Krankenhaus Sektor konzentrieren
natürlich ist der ambulante Sektor Reha
und Pflege ist ist ganz eng damit
verwoben
es geht den Menschen ja nicht nur darum
dass sie in Kliniken oder in Ambulanzen
gut versorgst sind sie ja auch die Frage
was kostet sie das über die
Krankenkassenbeiträge zum Beispiel
Stichwort Liquidität und Finanzprobleme
der Krankenhäuser Herr präsidenz
Missstände gibt ist häufig der Grund
entweder weil zu viel oder zu wenig Geld
im System ist wie ist es denn im
Gesundheitswesen vor allem bei den
Krankenhäusern naja als gesund im
Gesundheitswesen wenn man sich anguckt
die letzten Jahrzehnte und die nominal
die öffentlichen Ausgaben sind um 150%
im Schnitt gestiegen Verteidigung um 30%
Gesundheit und 250 also das ist der
Bereich wo am meisten Geld reingegangen
ist und im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen
Ländern ist es insbesondere die
Krankenhausversorgung die ihn immer
größeren Teil des Bruttoinlandsproduktes
mitnimmt und ich weiß viele sagen immer
noch wir müssen da noch mehr Geld
reinmachen aber als Arzt würde man auch
sagen irgendwann ist muss man vielleicht
überlegen habe ich jetzt zu viele
Tabletten gegeben und muss ich nicht das
Gegenteil machen natürlich kann ich also
nicht einfach sagen ich nehme euch jetzt
zehn Prozent des das Geld ist weg aber
wir müssen glaube ich weg nicht nur weil
das Geld knapp ist wegen anderer Dinge
die uns allen klar sind sondern weil wir
auch sehen wir kriegen
derzeit für ein zusätzlichen Euro den
wir ins System geben kriegen wir nicht
mehr mehr Gesundheit sondern es ist bald
die Probleme beim sich immer mehr das
heißt die Reform
so bitter das wird die muss nicht nur
davon ausgehen eigentlich es gibt nicht
nicht mehr Personal sondern es gibt auch
nicht mehr Geld wir müssen die Reform
hinkriegen das muss günstiger werden
statt statt mehr Geld ins System wird es
in fünf bis sieben acht Jahren zu spüren
können
ja anfangen können weil die anderen
erkennen keine erkennt
wenn ich jetzt richtig im Kopf habe 3%
des BIP also das Bruttoinlandsprodukt
gehen in die
Krankenhausversorgung 3,4 3,4 das ist
das hat mich überrascht wie hoch das ist
trotzdem es war vor zehn Jahren noch
drei und jetzt ist 3,4 trotzdem haben
Kliniken Geldprobleme Finanzprobleme
haben rote Zahlen wie geht das alles
zusammen auf der einen Seite ich muss
ein bisschen Trends zwischen der
Akutsituation also nur um die zwei Sätze
vielleicht dazu auch zu sagen also
momentan sind natürlich Kliniken auch
extrem von steigenden Energiekosten und
von der in angetroffen aber darum soll
es jetzt nicht primär gehen sollen wir
werden uns ja vor allem auf dem
langfristigen Blick und der
langfristigen Finanzierung zu es ist
schon so dass momentan
finanzierungsanreize dahingehend
bestehen dass ich jetzt mal wirklich
ganz plakativ gesagt Geld für Prozeduren
für Eingriffe bekomme und damit ein
Anreiz habe bestimmte Fachabteilungen
vorzuhalten und bei anderen ist es eben
weniger lukrativ und gerade um wirklich
bedarfsgerechtes Versorgungsangebot zu
schaffen also zu sagen ich habe die
grundsätzlichen Abteilung ich habe eine
grundsätzliche Anlaufstelle Chirurgie
innere Pädiatrie also Kinderheilkunde
Geburtshilfe die sind erreichbar und es
geht aber eben nicht darum möglichst
hohes versorgungslevel zu haben und das
geht eben nicht darum unbedingt eine
orthopädische Fachabteilung zu haben
über die ich Dir dies also
Fallpauschalen und damit ein höheres
Geld also höheren erlösgeneriere womit
ich die anderen Sachen querfinanzieren
kann
zu setzen haben wir dann vielen Stellen
eine fehlversorgung und an vielen
Stellen auch im letzten Endes Personal
was wir besser einsetzen es wird auch
viel Geld verbrannt dass woanders fehlt
man sagte dass die Bezahlung zum
Beispiel angeht konfähige Personal das
muss sich stark erhöhen damit genügend
überhaupt sich für diesen Beruf
interessieren als Anreiz auch bei Ärzten
ist glaube ich ähnlich bei
Krankenhäusern damit die Ärztinnen und
Ärzte nicht nach die Koffer packen und
nach Österreich in die Schweiz oder nach
Norwegen abhauen schon dabei und darf
ich da aber trotzdem noch den Eindruck
machen also weil es einfach wichtig ist
weil ich glaube man muss die die
Bedürfnisse auch wirklich korrekt
adressieren und das hatten sie auch
schon mit in die Werte gebracht also
eine Bezahlung ist immer gut natürlich
freut man sich immer mehr Geld und vor
allem über eine angemessene Bezahlung
auch im Vergleich zu anderen
Berufsgruppen aber letzten Endes sind
wir an einem Punkt wo die meisten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sowohl im
ärztlichen Bereich auch in der Pflege
sagen eigentlich geht es um eine
berufliche Planbarkeit eigentlich geht
es um Freizeitausgleich eigentlich geht
es darum zu wissen wenn ich im frei bin
werde ich nicht angerufen und muss eine
Schicht übernehmen und das sind ja Dinge
an dem man dann auch ansetzen muss also
nur mit mehr Bezahlung um das klar zu
sagen wenn wir diese Probleme nicht
lösen
sehe ich auch so aber trotzdem fehlt
Geld im System gerade gerade im
Krankenhausbereich und
effizienter sind ja für die
Investitionskosten zuständig und zahlen
wenn es hochkommt gut 50 Prozent dieser
Investitionskosten die restlichen Kosten
müssen die Krankenhäuser selber tragen
und dann versuchen die mit Angeboten
sozusagen diese fehlenden Einnahmen über
die Länder auszugleichen die
Fallpauschale zweckentfremdet die ja für
einzelne medizinische Leistungen eine
pauschale vorsieht dann nimmt man dann
die literativen Fälle und spart ein
Personal und dann hat man da deshalb
muss uns ja gut deswegen aber das ist
eher die vorhalteprobleme also die
Krankenhäuser werden sozusagen zu diesem
derzeit zu diesem Verhalten gezwungen
mir wäre es recht gewesen wenn in der
krankenhauskommission auch die Länder
und die Kassen mit sitzen würden weil
letztendlich finanzieren die das was
doch beschlossen wird derzeit kommen ja
keine Vorschläge von der Kommission
letzte die Kommission ich bin froh dass
es sie gibt aber die Vorschläge gekommen
die Vorschläge die kommen sind Kosten
mehr Geld aber sind nicht Ergebnisse
Beispiel tagesklinische Behandlung die
er jetzt sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit erregt
hat weil wir als Kommission sagen wir
haben halt in Deutschland immer noch zu
viele stationäre Patienten da sagt der
Koalitionspartner FDP gut aber nicht
ohne dass also die
diy's und die
Hybrid
definiert sind
200 Milliarden für energiebremse es wird
Geld bereitgestellt und dann macht man
sich Gedanken wo es hin soll und so sehe
ich das auch bei diesen Entwicklungen
dass man sagt das könnte man machen hört
sich gut an geht auch letztendlich in
die richtige Richtung
Salat aber kein Geld ein sondern es geht
erstmal nicht so also es kostet nicht
mehr Geld ich liebe mal mein Beispiel
von vollmissionen hat mehr die die
Abteilung im Krankenhaus im Blick aber
nicht das gesamte nein doch das stimmt
nicht also ich denke mal jetzt mal
wieder an an den Krebspatienten der in
Deutschland viermal stationär behandelt
wird im Ausland zweimal weil dann die
Chemotherapie Zyklen ambulant gemacht
werden solche Patienten haben wir im
Blick die sollen bei uns auch ambulant
gemacht werden damit ich jetzt schreien
gleich alle und sagen der sollen aber
die Krankenhäuser auch weniger Geld
kriegen ich weiß aber gar nicht was es
kostet ich muss erstmal die
Krankenhäuser Anreizen ist überhaupt zu
machen ich brauche Planung ich brauche
Krankenhausplanung endlich nach aber wir
brauchen 50 Jahren eine vernünftige
Krankenhausplanung die Planung für die
Zukunft ja soll gleich auf dem Niveau
einsetzen können was wirklich
gerechtfertigt ist sie will auch jetzt
nicht Krankenhausplanung machen auf der
Basis das Krebspatienten viermal
stationär behandelt werden wenn wir
eigentlich nur wenn sie eigentlich nur
zwei wenn zweimal genug wären also muss
ich irgendwie damit hinterher mein neues
krankenhaussystem auch genug also dass
das hinkommt die die Betten und die
Qualifikation mit den Patienten muss ich
die Patientenzahlen runter kriegen und
wir wissen aus dem Ausland wie kriege
ich Krankenhäuser dazu ihr Verhalten
wirklich zu ändern dass ich sage wir
wissen wir wissen die ambulante Bahnung
ist aber ihr kriegt das Geld in ihrer
Praxis aus was sie jetzt gerade
besprechen dieses System was passiert da
gehen sie konkret ja nicht meine wir
haben jetzt die Probleme auch was die
Finanzierung angeht was bedeutet das für
den für den Arzt für die Ärztin vor Ort
in welchem wirtschaftlichen Druck sind
sie zum Beispiel ausgesetzt dabei
also ich habe das große Glück dass ich
erstmal kein unmittelbaren
wirtschaftlichen Druck irgendwie spüre
in der Behandlung der Patienten Herr
Jansens hat gestern in einer Sendung ja
sehr klar noch mal zu verstehen gegeben
wie es auch sein kann es gibt ja
durchaus die Möglichkeit dass eben die
Fallpauschalen verlangen dass man oder
es gibt gewisse Abschläge für mehr
beatmungsstunden wenn wir jetzt einfach
mal in die Intensivmedizin gehen was
natürlich dazu verleitet Patienten unter
Umständen noch etwas länger zu beatmen
das ist mir tatsächlich nur aus der
Theorie geläufig aber ich glaube man
bekommt eine Idee was was passieren
könnte
wir merken
die wirtschaftlichen Zwänge nicht
unmittelbar in der Patientenbehandlung
da haben wir relativ freie Hand
tatsächlich natürlich muss das alles
Evidenz gedeckt sein und uns sinnvoll
was wir tun aber wo wir es merken ist
natürlich im an uns selber das muss man
einfach doch noch mal ganz klar sagen
Rudolf da habe ich eine noch ganz
grundsätzliche Frage in den letzten
Jahren sind ja viele Bereiche der da
seins Vorsorge privatisiert worden
Energiesektor Kommunikation Fernverkehr
wie sieht's da und wir sehen die nicht
sehr erfreulichen Folgen und
Konsequenzen dieser politisch gewollten
Entwicklung wie sieht es beim
Gesundheitswesen aus Gesundheit ist ganz
klar Daseinsvorsorge und da ist
Privatisierung vor allem wenn sie mit
einer gewinnen Abschöpfung einhergeht
nicht das wollen wir uns entwickeln
sollten nicht stärker bringt auch eine
Reihe von Problemen mit sich Outsourcing
in den Kliniken zum Beispiel zu nennen
ich glaube ganz so sehr können wir es an
der Stelle nicht vertiefen aber klar wir
haben gesetzlich festgelegt eine
Trägervielfalt ich glaube jetzt auch zu
behaupten man wird da viel knapp der
nächsten wenigen Jahre zurückdrehen das
wäre an der Stelle auch falsch aber klar
also eine Gewinnabschöpfung sollte es im
Gesundheitsbereich nicht geben und auf
der anderen Seite zu behaupten nur indem
man zum Beispiel ein gewinnernahmeverbot
prüft würden wir alle
Finanzierungsprobleme im
Gesundheitswesen lösen das ist auch
wiederum nicht angemessen also Aussage
besteht
zurückfahren man hat ja im Energiesektor
passiert er jetzt genau das
dass man weil man merkt was das für eine
vulnerable Infrastruktur ist aber wenn
Sie die Spielregeln trotzdem nicht
ändern dann haben sie ja trotzdem nichts
in letzter Konsequenz gekonnt also da
hat Herr Busse glaube ich gerade auch in
seinem Beitrag noch mal deutlich gemacht
also man muss einfach die die Anreize
für die Klingen auch so setzen dass sie
sagen sie sind eben da nicht schlechter
gestellt sie kriegen Vorhaltekosten
bezahlt es geht nicht um eine
strukturfinanzierung die sie Überfälle
generieren müssen die nicht notwendig
sind oder wo man die Indikation
zumindest auch in den von Ihnen
geschilderten Beispielen Fragen stellen
keinen Unterschied in der
Problemlage und auch im Verhalten ob es
ein kommunales Haus ist ob es ein freie
gemeinnütziges Haus ist oder ein
privates
da sehe ich das was ich wahrnehme
überall ähnliche Probleme und die
kommunalen sind in der Regel nicht
besser aufgestellt als die privaten wir
müssen dieses wir müssen wir müssen also
sollten hier keine ideologischen
Diskussionen führen sondern pragmatisch
an die Dinge rangehen und uns Gedanken
machen wie wir das System in Richtung
Qualität und Effizienzen schonend
weiterentwickeln können das heißt
in Nordrhein-Westfalen Kali Josef
Laumann hat hier
Beispiele aufgezeigt wie was gehen kann
indem man sagt dass also wenn man
bestimmte
Behandlungen durchführen will dass man
das entsprechend häufig machen muss
damit man da die entsprechende exper hat
und wer diese Fallzahlen nicht erreicht
der darf in Zukunft diese Eingriffe
nicht mehr durchführen und er sagt
Grundversorgung muss also überall
gesichert sein eine internistische
Abteilung eine chirurgische Abteilung in
Erreichbarkeit von 2025 Minuten das
würde man als diesen kalten
Strukturwandel dann auch beschreiben
also ich mache Vorgaben die das Haus gar
nicht anhalten kann aufgrund der
aktuellen Gelegenheit
personalgrenzen
Laumann also das sind sein Gutachten
reingeschrieben wie man die
Krankenhausplanung umgestalten soll und
entscheidender Schwachpunkt war ja
bisher das machen auch alle Bundesländer
so dass sie Fachabteilung planen Sie
sagen also ihr habt eine innere Medizin
und dann können die damit tun und lassen
was sie wollen in Erinnerung Medizin und
wir haben halt dem Laumann gesagt stell
um auf sogenannte Leistungsgruppen
Koalitionsvertrag also sprich ihr
braucht den Feststellungsbescheid wo
drinsteht ihr dürft Kardiologie machen
die in Herzkatheter erfordert und wenn
wenn das nicht habt dann dürft ihr den
Patienten mit Herzinfarkt während der
Herzkatheter braucht da nicht einfach
ohne Herzkatheter behandeln gar nicht
behandeln und das ist schon der Weg der
jetzt auch notwendig ist wir müssen
sozusagen die Medizin Denken in Gruppen
von Patienten die ähnlichen Bedarf haben
die bestimmte technische Voraussetzungen
wie linksherzkatheter oder bestimmtes
Personal bestimmte Fachärzte bestimmtes
fachpflegepersonal haben und die
Krankenhäuser kriegen zugewiesen welche
Arten von Patienten sie behandeln dürfen
das muss natürlich dann auch transparent
sein die Patienten muss ich sagen immer
meistens muss eigentlich an der
Notaufnahme dran stehen wenn sie
Herzschmerzen haben bitte hier nicht
reingehen weil wir haben gar kein
Herzkatheter das muss natürlich alles
transparent und messbar sein aber so
wird so wird vorangehen und natürlich
bleiben Krankenhäuser übrig
die wo man nicht so genau weiß wofür man
die eigentlich braucht weil weil die gar
keine Leistungsgruppe so richtig
erfüllen also alles was man braucht und
man braucht eine Institution die diese
Planung diese Qualität definiert wer ist
das welche das ist nach meiner Meinung
die selbst Verwaltung da sitzen die
Krankenhäuser zusammen mit den
Krankenkassen und könnten das wir haben
bei bei etwa 10 Indikationen den GBA
sozusagen beauftragt hier
Qualitätsstandards zu definieren die
dann auch in den Krankenhäusern
gemeinsame Bundesautobahn 150 Jahre wir
müssen also möglicherweise wir müssen
jetzt die Aufträge erteilen und dann
Zeitvorgaben geben vielleicht wann der
GBA diese
Qualitätsstandards definiert hat damit
es mal losgeht aber im Moment wird nur
diskutiert es wird über Dinge diskutiert
die eher mehr Geld kosten als dass sie
effizient sind bringen und deshalb
müssen wir noch einen anderen sind für
Zeitverzögerungen es ist halt mehrfach
jetzt hier angesprochen worden ein
ziemlich bekannter
landesgesundheitsminister wir haben 16
Bundesländer in Deutschland
mit durchaus
man kann sagen viel Kompetenz und macht
und auch einer Menge Eigensinn in der
Bildungspolitik zum Beispiel wird das
nicht eitel Freude verbreiten wie sie
sein der Gesundheitspolitik was wo liegt
die Gefahr für eine Reform im
Krankenhaus wenn da 16
Rezepte möglicherweise zur Umsetzung
hatte es passiert gar nichts und das
passiert nicht deshalb nichts weil es
uns gibt weil ja die Frage jetzt was die
letztendlich zuständig sind die Länder
das gibt 16 und die haben möglicherweise
ich will ihnen nichts in Mund legen aber
möglicherweise auch ganz
unterschiedlicherweise 16
unterschiedliche überzeugen die Länder
gehen das ist ja klar aber ich glaube
und da glaube ich sind wir nicht ganz
einer Meinung es ist schon auf der
Bundesebene so dass man
Rahmenbedingungen muss und dass man auch
eben gesetzliche Rahmenbedingungen für
eine Finanzierungsgrundlage so schaffen
muss dass dann die Länder gute
krankenhausbettenpläne daraus machen
können und ja gerade auch an dem
Beispiel was sie genannt haben also
machen wir es doch mal konkret wenn sie
sagen wir machen das Ganze nur über
Qualitätsstandards dann führt das doch
aber jetzt auch schon dazu dass zwei
Krankenhäuser die vielleicht in der
relativ nahen Distanz zueinander sind
beide versuchen eine bestimmte
Fachabteilung erleben zu halten sich
beide die Patienten und Patienten dafür
aus dem Einzugsbereich holen und wir
eine bessere Qualität hätten wenn man
sagt man konzentriert diese
Fachabteilung an dem einen Ort das
andere Krankenhaus kriegt eine andere
kein Krankenhaus muss aufgrund dessen
Angst haben dass Vorhaltekosten nicht
angemessen finanziert sind und man kann
einfach eine Planung gehen aber da ist
lösen wir ja nicht nur über diese
Qualität Zustande Krankenhausplanung hin
ich habe vor einigen Wochen mit dem
krankenhausplaner in meinem Bundesland
gesprochen der hat mir gesagt wir
diskutieren und die Länder diskutieren
seit Jahrzehnten und kriegen keine
Krankenhausplanung hin wir brauchen hier
Vorgaben der selbst Haltung die die
Länder dann die die Länder dann oder die
Krankenhäuser umsetzen müssen und auf
der anderen Seite haben wir die Länder
die können dann eine entsprechende
Regionalplanung machen die
Feinjustierung damit also in der Region
sie wollen einen Einsatz gesagt
Krankenhausplanung durch die
Selbstverwaltung also auch durch die
Krankenhäuser inwieweit sind die
Ärztinnen und Ärztinnen da einbezogen
diese Krankenhausplanung also ich
zumindest nicht
ja das ist ein Manko ja wie bei vielen
Dingen finde ich die letztlich ja an den
Leuten Vorbeigehen die es betrifft also
mir ist nicht bekannt inwieweit das
Pflegepersonal zum Beispiel Einfluss hat
auf verschiedene Reform die sind beim
DBA sind alle alle in irgendeiner Form
eingebunden also das ist ja sozusagen
die Selbstverwaltung aller aller
sozusagen Leistungserbringer im
Gesundheitswesen die in diesem
gemeinsamen Bundesausschuss zusammen
sitzen sich verständigen sollen und wenn
die sich nicht verständigen in einem
bestimmten Zeitrahmen dann gibt es eine
unabhängige Vorsitzenden der das letzte
Wort dann hat aber man weiß dass es ein
Ergebnis gibt
aus Sachsen und Thüringen berichten
wollen also da steht zum Beispiel
jeweils eine Überarbeitung des
krankenhausplans an und beide
Bundesländer sind gerade dabei dass in
strukturprozesse zu gießen die es vorher
so nicht gab nämlich mit einer breiten
Beteiligung unter anderem eben auch mit
den Leistungserbringern also auch im
Ärztinnen und Ärzte sind dabei auch die
Pflege ist mit dabei und das ist
natürlich besonders wichtig also solche
mit 16
zum Thema da wir selten in einer Sendung
drei Ärzte eine Gesundheitsexperten
haben oder Ärztinnen heute hat der
Bundesgesundheitsminister die Eckpunkte
für die Cannabis Legalisierung die im
Kabinett verabschiedet worden sind
bekannt gegeben also Cannabis Rauschgift
Legalisierung zum Genuss zum zum
privaten Gebrauch was ist davor zu
halten haben Sie dazu hier kurz wir
haben nur noch wenige Sekunden Zeiten
finden ja
eine gute Entscheidung also wir müssen
uns mit dieser Herausforderung
auseinandersetzen das braucht Zeit weil
wir waren jetzt in Kanada im Ausschuss
Kanada hat 14 Gesetze gebraucht um eine
Entscheidung zu treffen und wir haben
noch Europa deshalb ist das ein Projekt
wo also Gesundheitsschutz wichtiger sein
muss als
die Entkriminalisierung und aber wie
gesagt wir müssen positiv an diese Sache
rangehen und versuchen die Jahre eine
Lösung zu finden und dann haben wir das
auch noch kurz geschafft Herr Busse hat
schon auf die Uhr gedeutet dass die Zeit
abgelaufen ist dass sie bei der
Krankenhausplanung am besten in einem
Jahr alles gerne schon gehabt hätten und
bei Cannabis jetzt mit zehn Jahre
Schiene andeuten also ich würde mich
auch da freuen wenn wir das schneller
beobachten ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen
für die Diskussion hier Liebe
Zuschauerin liebe Zuschauer morgen in
der Phönix Runde haben wir was anderes
Bazooka Wumms und doppelwumms wer soll
das bezahlen
aktuell ist und weiteres sind Phoenix
der Tag mit Maja Weber darin die von mir
gerade erwähnte Pressekonferenz von Karl
Lauterbach zur Cannabis Legalisierung in
ausführlicher Form bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]